hey you're an entrepreneur obviously if
you're watching this content you're
smart you're intelligent you're gonna
make it one day you're gonna look good
you're gonna wear nice suits nice
jewelry nice cars nice homes and even
have a lot of options but the one thing
is there's a lot of mistakes
entrepreneurs make when they date today
I'm gonna give you ten of them number
one this one's a little bit hard because
so many people want to show up you know
who they're dating you know their new
boyfriend or their new girlfriend I want
to go out there and show to them this is
my rule I use for a long time never ever
show a boyfriend or girlfriend out too
early you don't know if it's gonna work
out or not my rule of thumb was six
months if it's past six months then it's
public if it's not it's private now
listen don't get me wrong if you haven't
dinner at Ruth's Chris or somewhere like
that and somebody sees you it's a
different story I'm here with my friend
we're having dinner together right but
to go around in the office holding hands
kissing each other in front of everybody
way too early let me tell you why I
don't like it O'Neal ask me a question
said pal what's your problem with this
here's what the challenge is when
another person working with you sees you
with too many new relationships it
doesn't show too much stability for me
to be wanting to work with you
matter of fact can inspire somebody to
do the same thing as well I like
stability and the more talent you want
that's high your talent they want to see
somebody they're working with that is
stable in their business life number two
okay so you look good you work out he
looks good he works out you're dating
each other you're dating him or her
whatever it is right and all I'm saying
like oh my gosh we have this passion you
know we do so well with salsa she's so
feisty and firing your entrepreneur
freakin passion and she's also
passionate it's ridiculous Pat you got
to see this how we are I'm telling you
we're so passionate together yeah but
are you compatible okay I dated a girl
for three years she was a Libra I'm a
Libra we were passionate to the point
where World War 3 was gonna get started
you cannot confuse passion in the
bedroom versus compatibility for years
to come if you're dating somebody
because you're just making some
passionate extracurricular activities
for that time it's fine but you're
looking at somebody that's wanting to be
your girlfriend boyfriend somebody gonna
come out in public and say this is my
girl this is my man
then that's a whole different story ask
yourself the question how compatible the
two of you guys are together because if
you're not the time you're gonna spend
thinking about the issue of the argument
you have with them because you are not
compatible together is going to affect
your business number three so listen
this next one I've seen it so many times
and it's the exact formula for disaster
here's what it is
say my name is Mary I date John he's my
boyfriend I like him I love him maybe
but it's too early right or I got a new
girlfriend she's my squeeze she's my
girlfriend we're dating we're an item
there's nobody else in my life but I'm
running a successful business right and
she starts coming and I start asking her
for advice but she's never ran a
business she's never even been in our
industry start asking her advice and if
she comes in your work environment and
she starts having authority to tell your
employees and your salespeople what to
do he let me explain this to you have
you ever been in that kind of an
environment where just because your boss
has a new girlfriend or a new boyfriend
and they tell you how to do business but
they've only been dating that person for
nine months and they have no clue how
your business works and that person is
given him or her the authority to talk
to you like they're your boss how do you
feel about it when that happened to you
let me tell you there's nothing more
annoying than that so if you're dating
somebody just because I love somebody
that doesn't mean you run the business
just because you're my boyfriend or my
girlfriend that doesn't mean you know
what you're doing to tell other people
what to do this is the business I've
been running now by year two years three
years four years five years later and
you're involved in a workplace for two
years and everybody sees you as one as
somebody that's committed complete
different story until then very subtle
very very subtle but go with your gut
because you know the business your
girlfriend boyfriend you're dating is
there somebody you love they don't know
about your business number four so
here's another awkward thing happens
when you date somebody new and you're
kind of going through and let's just say
one is the earner she makes the money
she's the entrepreneur he doesn't or he
makes the money she doesn't and there is
a feeling from the person that makes
money that the other person is trying to
take advantage their status money-wise
okay so whatever position you're in if
you're the money person the way you set
it up it's on you if you feel that way
and if you're not the person making the
money you got to set the tone that I
have my own money as well so this is how
I suggest going if the relationships
taking place
with an earner and another person that
makes money but maybe not her kind of
money we have three accounts her account
his account our account our account I
put five hundred you put five hundred
it's like Dutch I put it that you put it
that what do you want to do we're gonna
go on a trip together because I want to
get to know you better
no problem I don't have to pay for your
flight I don't have to pay for your
hotel
we're gonna go split no problem by the
way I suggest this up front because the
money person later on doesn't have to
worry about the fact that this is the
motivation of her or him because he just
wanted the money when you do that if she
wants to go by $5,000
Chanel personal problems she does it
with her money if he wants to go about
$8,000 rims on his car that's okay it's
his money our money this is what we
spent what did we spend money on $800 no
problem $400 $400 that was a flight to
Vegas hotel was $400 a night we stayed
two nights as 1,200 bucks dinner was
$300 we are good to go babe no problem
no one is leaving feeling like one is
taken advantage of the other now later
on wants to get serious then it's a
different story and by the way even at
that point I still recommend three
accounts because it minimizes arguments
number five okay so this next one it's
from many many personal experiences with
this sometime when you have a girlfriend
and you're new you're dating you're
running your business and it's like
you're dating each other you're new it's
exciting stuff that's going on you're
like hey you know I can take a longer
lunch let's meet at 12 o'clock have
lunch and then let's go to my place it's
12 o'clock you leave okay one o'clock
you finish lunch then you go back to the
place and he took a two-hour break or
she took her two hour break then it's 2
o'clock 3 o'clock
that's one more time right that's 4
o'clock oh my gosh I'm so tired
you know what I'm just gonna cancel my
appointments tonight I'm gonna let
everybody know something came up
takes hey my assistant hey Mary can you
call everybody and tell them my
opponents gotta cancel yet something
just came up
ok I understand it's an emergency family
think private I don't want to really
disclose it yeah of course you're not
gonna disclose and it's private because
it's in your bedroom you just went out
of two or three times you're tired
you're having a cigarette right for
those that smoke cigarettes right then
you're done so guess what
you do this once it's like you can do it
again tomorrow yeah let's do it again
tomorrow
oh my god
I can next week Monday same routine same
time your place my place car expedition
your business is gone and you're broke
and you're an employee why because your
schedule got screwed up the moment you
started dating this new girlfriend of
yours a new boyfriend of yours done
you're back being an employee be very
careful when you do this schedule if for
the weekend or a late night not
throughout the day number six so you
start dating somebody new you like him
this is cool you're having fun and say
hey man I make a lot of money what if I
kind of want to buy her a nice $3,000
purse to show her Who I am
hey let's go to a Louboutin store I love
you girl I got you listen to calm you
know full moon you're with me Micro has
the best type of stuff
here's a $3,500 Louie button oh my gosh
you're so amazing my ex never did this
and guys or your ex now of course you
know well I wish it was like my ex was
it yes yeah you walk around feeling so
proud of yourself which you don't
realize is this you've officially set an
expectation of if he buys me a Louis
Vuitton bag two months into it guess
what next year I want you to buy me a
Louis Vuitton store and if you don't
it's a disappointment because you can no
longer go up what's above a $3500 purse
what is it
yeah you're gonna go by Chanel $5,500
purse what's above that there's only one
way to go up if you go from a $3,500
Louie Vuitton purse to $350 coach back
guess what she's gonna tell you you know
what babe used to love me babe what
happened I think we had a different
relationship I used to buy me high
quality stuff coach it hurts my feelings
you screwed up because you spoiled them
too early rather than saying you know my
girl who's gonna be with me and it's
gonna be with me long time let me tell
what I'm gonna be doing after she shows
coming cuz he relationships both ways
she shows me come work together he shows
me commitment I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do this but five years from now 10
years from now 15 years from now and if
he or she sticks around that may be a
keeper but if you or she doesn't stick
around because she wants more Rivertown
backs let her go des Jimmy who's gonna
buy that $3,500 back and six months
later she's gonna leave him for another
Jimmy that's gonna buy her the next
Chanel back meanwhile you save yourself
$22,000 on a bank account number seven
so listen I have this friend she's very
attractive very attractive beautiful and
she makes very good money I've been
working with
for a while mentored she's done very
very good for herself we can say she's
drop-dead gorgeous I'm not gonna name
who it is she's very pretty we start
talking she's dating a guy good-looking
guy solid guy but I don't know this guy
but he's a good-looking guy
perfect she calls me for advice about
finances so anytime she calls I'm
talking to I'm always gonna assume that
hey maybe the boyfriend is also
listening all right ok no problem I
asked is he is he not he's not we've
known each other for many many years
great so then I told her so were you out
what relationships gone very serious you
know about great so have you had the
conversation with them about a prenup or
how you guys gonna manage finance it oh
my gosh why would I do that we love each
other I said oh yeah kind of know you
love each other but you got a kid and
and he's got kids and who's more
important your kid or him well of course
my kid well then that's great so you
know I'm saying like this kid is gonna
rely on you for the business that you
run that makes you millions of dollars
per you you got to make the right
decision for you because what if
tomorrow something changes how do I
bring up that conversation how do you
have sex the first time it's awkward the
first time right so a lot of people like
to drink before they have sex the first
time because I don't want to think a lot
right because it's first time it's a
little bit uncomfortable for some people
you got to bring it up I don't know how
to bring it up you got to bring it up so
finally she brought it up and they had
the conversation and he was open to it
nothing happened with the relationship
they're still together guess what that
shows me maybe this guy's really
committed I'm not here for your money
good for you but she is now making the
right sound decision that's gonna
protect her wealth her net worth or
business and this guy is showing
commitment to say I'm not here for your
money I love you
that is an ideal situation why I
recommend entrepreneurs who are
established that have already made their
millions of dollars to protect their
business and have this conversation with
them saying hey if we get married this
is something that's important to me I
won't have a serious relationship if we
get married we're gonna have my money
you're gonna have your money and we're
gonna have our money and whatever we buy
together is our money but if you want to
go out and buy a you know $6,000 wheels
for your car that I don't want to buy
you bond with your money if I want to go
out there and buy $6,000 purse for
myself I buy with my money but if we
want to buy a couch for the house and
fix it up it's for ground we buy it with
our money is this fair yes great love it
babe I'm so glad we're on the same
page together another less argument that
we're gonna have moving forward because
it's an argument I had in the past I
just gave you the playbook gotta have
the conversation about bringing up and
separate accounts what's your next
person your date number eight okay so
this mistake I see all the time so let
me tell how I see this mistake say one
of my executive or somebody or mentor I
work with I need their new girl for the
first time okay and she or one of our
executive it's a girl who's dating a guy
for the first time and I meet him or her
the first time and this is how they talk
to me oh hey how are you okay and they
had me to look - man look oh wow oh hi
how are you okay I heard a lot good to
meet you I automatically know that this
guy complained about some part of our
relationship in the past to her or him
so which means our relationship is
already in a box because he's
complaining about his work environment
to people that he's dating or she's
dating right now somebody would super
then Who am I supposed to talk to what
am I supposed to do do you know how many
times I have seen the person that's
running a business prevent themselves
from blowing up because they complain so
much to the person that they sleep with
every night to the point where the
person that they sleep with every night
all they care about is for their partner
to be happy and at peace and indirectly
the new girlfriend or boyfriend that
doesn't know the work environment they
push them away from the business out and
they don't even know they're doing this
they'll say things like this babe I
can't believe you did that you I can't
believe she do you know what you should
do babe you should leave you should
leave baby you just don't look happy but
I sure I should leave you should leave I
should leave
usually I'm gonna leave tomorrow okay
baby let's go good good yeah boom it
just cost yourself a couple million
bucks
not smart we've all been in that
situation before I'm just telling from
experience
don't complain all the time about your
workplace to your girl or your boyfriend
don't because it just backfires on you
10 X number nine so you're dating him
you're dating her she liked you she
liked you you look good oh my gosh he's
sexy you're together for three months
six months things are going good nine
months you're no longer working
in the morning because you're sleeping
in and you're no longer working out late
at night because you want to see her and
your body you were 12 percent body fat
now 14 percent 16 percent 22 percent
desserts all together oh my god we
should share this chocolate fudge you
know this you know this whole volcano
think that they do with the vanilla
let's have it together I love you so
much here but you can put your arm
through it okay you think about baby I
love you so much we're eating things
together I love when we have ice cream
together yeah you gained 50 pounds have
an ice cream together your body's gonna
you need energy to run your business you
don't have the energy anymore so just
because you're dating somebody new and
you finally have somebody lock down that
doesn't mean you let your body go
because running a business requires a
lot of energy and stamina by the way
stamina is gonna help you in other
aspects of your life as well so you date
somebody new you love them things are
going good you're having fun keep
working out if you can find ways to work
out together because you kind of want
her or him to still stay in shape but
keep that body together and number 10 so
here's one thing I'm not a big fan of
and explain to what it is so there are a
lot of things that we do as an
entrepreneur so if you're running a
business that's insider information that
can't even be leaked to your
boyfriend/girlfriend maybe even your
wife or your husband at times they can't
I mean think about a CIA agent can't
bring everything home to their wife and
they say what happens that I can't tell
you babe but some strange things happen
today
can I no no you know it's part of my
obligation as abyss i I can't as a CIA
agent there are certain things they can
bring home could be money related could
be compliance relate could be personal
life or later there are a lot of things
I know about the people I do business
with that is very deep that even my wife
doesn't know about because that part is
not part of our business so people say
but that's your wife
it doesn't matter that's not part of our
business I'm not required to expose
every single secret about everybody that
what I do at the Home Office to
everybody need to do you why you expose
that the next time you are having dinner
with your CFO or some arias your
boyfriend your girlfriend your wife your
husband says oh so how is that thing
going on I knew you guys are dealing
with such-and-such and how is that going
on your CFO no longer trusts you to tell
you everything because they know you
leak everything home and they're worried
because if one day your relationship
with her or him does
work out she could care less about
exposing him because that's not value to
her
that's value to you he won't tell you
anything anymore now you are not getting
all the information that you need to
know to grow your business to the next
level so what's the point you don't need
to give insider information to everybody
it's only the people on the inside they
need to know about it now if he your
partner is on the inside or she's on the
inside different story but if they're
not you don't need to expose it to
everybody so if you're watching this
right now saying Pat got deep today with
relationships look business is deep and
there's a reason why most businesses
don't last because a personal leading it
doesn't know how to process all these
different issues and the person they
date has a lot of influence on how their
business grows now for some of you that
are watching us in st. Pat are there any
other content on this topic that I can
consume yes to videos I want you to
watch one is called who to marry how to
marry which is also very entertaining
but that's one video I would watch the
other one is 15 things to know before
you date an entrepreneur which by the
way both of these videos have been
watched by partners husband and wife
boyfriend/girlfriend together so many
times because it puts them on the same
page moving forward so you may not just
want to watch this videos by yourself
you may want to share with your
boyfriend or your girlfriend so they're
on the same page with you as well so
last but not least if you haven't yet
subscribed to the channel do so we're
about to cross eight hundred thousand
subs two hundred thousand subs away from
getting to a million our first live
value tainment conference which I cannot
wait to meet you for two-and-a-half days
we're just gonna be strategizing about
business on how to take your business to
the next level we will announce the
dates and we'll get together 120 days
after we cross 1 million subs take
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
all right thank you this good one yeah
Patrick we're rolling you're you're
serious yeah
no we're not seriously obviously we'll
cut this part let's okay so let's get
right into it